I heard I don't know if it's true that
uh that you auditioned and when I was
delighted when I heard it
um a number of years ago for James Bond
the the and and the role went to Daniel
Craig as we all know but I think it'd be
terrific I really do I really do think
it'd be terrific thank you I told so
many people I would be I practically
told my family I was going to be right
which was which was always did you uh
when you walked out of the uh rehearsal
did you I mean out of the audition did
you see Daniel Craig sitting there with
his sides and go good good luck good
luck yes good luck DC yes
no no it was one of those moments where
it was it was true that you they were
floating this idea that that the the
next James Bond would be plucked at an
early age out of the Naval Academy yeah
and they had all these great ideas like
the bond himself will kind of like you
know was gonna pick the next candidate
to fill the role of double seven right
so everyone was like oh my God this
could this could be true we're at the
right age it's gonna be amazing and and
this this I think we were relatively
large group of kind of
young white men who were invited to read
Casino Royale put on a nice dark suit
and go to the broccoli's office which
which was a sight to behold the office
itself that looks out over the um Green
Park Green Park I think in London was
just was just unbelievable I mean this
is the family that's been produced in
the film since Dr no yes yeah since the
first one yes so it was it was
terrifying in itself that you walked in
there was a number of faces in that
little anti-chamber that you knew who
were very successful and you're like oh
oh God and then we all sat there
sweating and making terrible small talk
and then you're invited in
um and this they're all behind this
enormous desk and there's so much
memorabilia around that you want to
start talking about in family sure yeah
uh and you're trying to trying to remain
kind of very serious and Suave at the
same time
you're trying to be I know Bond Channel
Bond oh God it's so oh it's just so
depressing when you look back at it and
so what are they do they uh how did you
think the audition went
well I'm not playing Bond
nor have I been I thought well maybe yes
it was a close call between you no
obviously in my mind it was you know I
kept telling everyone between me and
Daniel Craig like it's not he's been off
of the part stop saying that
um he's made three of you yeah yes I
know but it's something I've got a
chance yeah
um they're just using him to get my
price down yes
think of him as a warm-up so they um
they basically said have you read
because you know Royal and said yes and
then they just said a question I hadn't
anticipated for the for loving of money
they went
so what would you do different with Bond
and then I was like oh
I was like is this so what kind is this
the trick question or is it a genuine
question
and I and as a terrible joke I said
limp
and it went in and
over except except it got worse because
it was a quiet it went very quiet so
then I thought I would double down and
said eye patch and then and then and
then and then I just and then I just
fell apart and it lasted about 30
seconds after that I love uh bond with
not just a little limp but a decided
aggressive limp yeah and a lot of uh
I'll get you someone help me
also do you think of the kick element so
they were like did you get that from you
know missions he's like no I had polio
and Ricketts as a child the Navy are
very accommodating
so I didn't need enough fresh fruit he
has a child yes so so yeah it was very
it was very brief after that there was a
quick kind of a test yes yes well thank
you so much for coming in you're like oh
that was my bond moment what's your bond
moment yeah yeah and I think of that
often but then I still think of the
question I go what
as you can tell I don't I still don't
have a coherent answer that would have
wowed them I often wonder what Daniel
Craig said to that question what would
you have said to that question
I would have said uh that's a you know
what if
what if he's very claustrophobic
uh does he has little he has little
ticks you know so he doesn't take
elevators he only takes stairs that's
good uh it doesn't like the oh how about
a bond that doesn't like to fly
and so there you know the way because
most those movies are
um he's hopping yes from he's in London
obviously yes but then suddenly he's in
you know Sam Moritz but then he's in uh
you know he's on the Ivory Coast he's
all over the place yeah a bond who needs
to
it's in his contract I don't feel yeah
that's good so it's Long Boat Ride yes
yes or train trains yes trains and then
boats yes he always cutting them in
travel exhausted yeah and M is always
saying well is Bond there well no let's
see where he is now he's yeah see
brilliant you can see that yeah I can
see that yes I could have yeah and uh I
know yeah think of the film career
I'd have had yeah with talent and a
completely different face
[Laughter]
yes you'll be thinking it'll haunt you
Carrie will say why are you twisting and
turning in the bed yes because I have a
problem with the Pope
is that what you're calling it now yes
is that the euphemism for it yes it is I
have a problem with the Pope yes